you know what's in my head and not going
away Oh God
it's there it's not going anywhere but
now we have a trailer for guardians of
the galaxy so now I talk about it this
is a teaser trailer so it's an
introduction to the characters we get to
see abusive stepdad grain avatar Rocket
Raccoon
Treebeard from Lord of the Rings and
star-lord now like how they're doing
Starla all right first of all I know
nothing about the comic book yeah
secret's out I know nothing about the
guardians of the galaxy comic book which
this movie seems to be playing off of
because guardians of the galaxy they're
like the B Squad they're the not
Avengers know how I always say the best
thing a movie can do is know what it is
that's what this movie's done I think
one of most random people and be like
hey do you know who Iron Man Incredible
Hulk Thor do you know those guys Marvel
and then go name off any of the
guardians of the galaxy before this
trailer came out they'd be like there's
a squirrel right my pony as Marvel
Studios was like a lot of people don't
know who these characters are so the
misfits they're the underdogs they're
the B Squad let's play that up make a
fun movie looks like they have because
Marvel Studios knows like no we're gonna
do the movie like this yeah we get it
Warner Brothers and Christopher Nolan
they make comic book movies dark and
everyone seems to think they have to
make their comic book movie dark
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
Marvel's like we don't care we're gonna
do guardians of the galaxy how we should
do guardians of the galaxy which is
people should have fun with the movie
and the movie looks really fun whoo guys
still in my head is still not going that
song in the trailer surprisingly goes
well with the trailer it's the comedic
town when the title comes up you're like
hey is it a comedy boo and everyone's
kicking ass it's exciting it's a perfect
trailer song star-lords doing this
he's all oh I'm sorry I didn't know how
that machine worked I was like bringing
out the old-school jokes hey I support
that that's my boy which also shows that
he's not as cool as he wants to be don't
take his headphones oh he'll get pissed
I feel like this could be like Iron Man
remember when I saw the trailer for Iron
Man when I worked at a movie theater my
boss was like what do you think of Iron
Man I was like it's gonna be a 90-minute
piece of like like Fantastic Four -
he agreed and then I saw it it was like
holy crap that's not a 90-minute piece
of that movie's awesome and now
here we are many Marvel movies later
many successful world-dominating Marvel
movies later guardians of the galaxy
could be like that if
hit this movie right no one's taken over
Marvel you can try a DC DC's gonna feel
all the desperation think of your life
apparently that's just what we feel we
need to do looking forward to this movie
a lot more because I hadn't seen
anything on it people who saw Comic Con
footage were like it looks awesome and
now I saw the trailer and I'm like that
looks awesome
so the guardians of the galaxy trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it and are you a fan of the comic
book and did this do it justice or are
you like wrong tone I heard it's not the
wrong tone I heard it's actually the
perfect tone from comic book fan so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more